I need the wide come on I'm so close we
have to go back we have to go back
[Music]
we are back in the life of the life I am
I lost my save the game wouldn't [ __ ]
work so we're back in a new world don't
worry we'll find Shannon the shark again
it's all gonna be okay see I can paddle
anywhere paddle on the tree paddle on
the tree
Oh dr. Crabbe you're back you're back in
my Mane let me paddle you all right well
let's let's do some deep diving nailing
it I did this see there's nothing Oh oh
this is just a towel box
a hammer what what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do with a hammer that's awesome
we can sledgehammer the Sharks oh look
at the shark hey shark Shannon Shannon
wait up Shannon it's me it's me Shannon
Hey oh how you doing [ __ ] Shannon why
would you guys check there we go you're
dead hey boys are you doing shut up all
right let's go Shannon get on the boat
god damn you're fat Shannon Jesus Christ
all right well let's go to our next
destination
I got damn it you're too fat Shannon
you're too fat let's do it Shannon style
Shannon you'll be my paddle I love your
boats I'll love you too Shannon I'm so
happy we're back together poets I can't
tell you how happy this makes me
[Applause]
look I'm a piss I can fly Shannon my
senpai I love you so much Shannon it
[ __ ] you almost kill me Shannon oh god I
don't know what's going on oh my god Oh
God what the [ __ ] again I can't tell if
I beds I've seen the future oh my god
I'm so [ __ ]
I am so [ __ ] I am Shannon Shannon
Shannon Shannon oh god I think I lost
Shannon hey new island [ __ ] you old
island this is gonna be the best of an
avian cooker my crabs
I miss Shannon I wish she was here right
now I'd be so happy what the [ __ ] was
that what the [ __ ] was that
no [ __ ] way microwave sound Shannon
Shannon Shannon it's me
Burch oh god there's - Shannon's doors
chánatos jiggle that ass for me Chanin
jiggle that ass I like it - clatters I
said jiggle jiggle jiggle jiggle jiggle
jiggle wiggle wiggle bounce trim in the
booty jiggle what there's not a single
cloud this world is really [ __ ] with
me isn't it are you kidding me
I can't see now Shannon Shannon where I
am I see something out there oh god it's
a shark
oh god it's a great white shark stab at
my jokes
doh - oh god oh god oh god okay I didn't
I didn't oh oh I'm safe I'm safe how are
you gonna do now [ __ ] can I kill a
great white shark is that even possible
ah you want a nibble on my tits don't
you alright you know what [ __ ] it
Yolo come on come on come on come on
don't be so [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus Christ
I'm gonna stab you until Jesus says no
it's Jesus saying no I don't think so oh
my god they have so much [ __ ] health
come on oh no they don't rag doll they
don't wreck the whole ah go tree no stay
on the to fly on the wing search
blight read The Adventures of tree and
here's the trilogy look at this hurry
[ __ ] Potter [ __ ] that was
stranded deep if you want more and
enjoyed this video please leave a like
and as always thank you for watching
stay awesome bros
[Applause]
[Music]